so coverage is important in making a
movie when you're doing it when you're
in the middle of it all you forget that
you want to get a thing moving and and
you know you never know but if you can
get that angle yeah and you miss the
angle I remember when I was working with
Francis we were doing this funeral scene
and and it was over the shooting day was
over we lost you know we lost the light
and I remember leaving
and I felt rather good about it being
over because I was tired in a long day
and of course you know I'm not behind
the camera I don't know what's going on
I so Francis sitting there he was crying
literally sobbing and I went over and I
said what's the matter he said
they won't give me another setup and I
thought
this is how much it meant to him yeah
that extra setup you know and for people
who don't know it's it can make the
difference in a scene